répondre à la demande, comme
nous l'e
- On a combien de palettes à
Moisson Montréal cet après-midi?
ébastien Patrice dit
passer son temps au téléphone
pour convaincre dees
et des entreprises de
lui vendre des denrées.
Son but : garnir les étagèresete
établie dans l'arrondissement
Côte-des-Neiges,es-Neiges,es-Ne.
JEAN-SÉBASTIEN PATRICE, DG,
cafétéria communautaire MultiCaf
- C'est fou. Il masité, il manqe
les produits de base. Quand
on parle de produits de base,
que ce soit le riz, la farine,
le sucre peine six mois,
Jean-Sébastien Patrice
a écoulé son budget
d'un million de dollars
dédié à
Il dit n'avoir que deux choix.
ssure d'avoir
suffisamment de denrées ou
capable de refuser des gens.
- Au tot- Au tot- Au tot- Au tot
en aide à 7000 résidents
Côte-des-Neiges. Mais pour l'ene
du Québec, ce sont
près de 671 000 personnes ont rs
aux banques alimentaires.
En 2019, elles étaient 500 000.
MARTIN MUNGER, DG, Les Banques
alimentaires du Qu
- C'est pas normal que dans
une société comme le Québec,
on ait... une partie aussite dei
n'est pas capable de se nour
- Le directeur des Banques
alimentaires demande plus d'fint
et de ses partenai
surtout que Québec s'attaque
véritablement à lavec des solutt
long terme comme, e,
la hausse du salaire minium.
Pour ceu
la visite à la banque
alimentaire devient de
moins en moins embarrassante.
- En cours de route,
j'ai compris : les gens
sont là pour nous aider
et non pour nous rabaisser.
a faim
se multiplient au Québec :
ses retraités, des gens qui
ont un revenu ou qui reçoivent
en font maintenant partie.Les Bs
du Québec avoue que
son résepour noupour noupour no.
Ici Gabrielle Proulx,
Radio-Canada, Mon